[Música]
durante mais de 30 anos eu organizei
eventos trabalhei nessa área com muita
dedicação muito embora a organizar
servente eu sempre gostei de fotografia
da natureza com a fotografia aprendi
muitas coisas
uma delas é quando você quer fazer uma
fotografia de natureza
você precisa se desconectar se
desconectar do mundo digital para se
conectar com o mundo real se sentir
parte do fluxo sentido à vida passando e
entender que você faz parte do todo
outro exercício que a gente tem quando a
gente faz fotografia da natureza é o da
paciência na cidade a gente não tem
muita mas quando a gente viaja para
lugares mais distantes
é a nossa primeira lição saber esperar a
hora certa
saber esperar um animal que a gente quer
ver até ele chegar algumas vezes ele não
chega mas pelo menos a gente tem a
fotografia de natureza ensina também que
é preciso ter mais atenção na cidade a
gente não liga muito para os detalhes
mas a natureza existem detalhes que
fazem toda a diferença
a fotografia de natureza ensina também a
gente conheceu nossos próprios limites
às vezes a gente não sabe até onde pode
ir
a gente vai tentando às vezes não dá
certo mas são os desafios que movem as
pessoas
a fotografia de natureza ensina também
há gente que se a gente quer fazer uma
imagem de um lugar mais distante mais
inóspito
a gente precisa enfrentar alguns riscos
esses riscos valem a pena porque a gente
quer chegar em lugares mais diferentes
do que aqueles que a gente está
acostumado a gente sabe que existe uma
responsabilidade muito grande de trazer
a realidade daquele lugar para pessoas
que dificilmente sairão dos seus
conforto das suas casas para poder ir
para um lugar
como esse e correu se isso que a gente
passa mas no caminho a gente encontra
muitas coisas improváveis que vamos
surpreendendo
existe também o encontro da luz e muitas
coisas se revelam de uma maneira que a
gente não estava esperando que a
fotografia de natureza traz também
surpresas no caminho
por isso é preciso ficar tão atento o
tempo todo
a fotografia de natureza traz também os
presentes
quando a gente tem paciência na nossa
primeira viagem em família fantástica
tinha duas imagens que eu gostaria de
trazer a primeira é a imagem da nossa
família e eu só consegui fazer essa
fotografia no último dia da nossa viagem
porque nunca tinha tempo nem sempre a
gente tinha missões e aquele nunca era o
dia certo e no final antes de vir embora
eu consegui convencer o meu marido o a
mesmo a parar no iceberg surgiu diante
de nós um e se bebe enorme parecia sim
uma grande catedral e eu disse são os
gelos são sempre tão instáveis mas esse
tão grande
possivelmente vai ser mais estável a
gente vai poder desembarcar nele então
nós atacamos naquela catedral e
desembarcamos quando montei o cenário
assim compus a família para fazer essa
fotografia
eu entendi que o fotógrafo ele tem
poderes mágicos
o fotógrafo consegue congelar um
instante e esse instante hoje representa
muito para mim porque esse cenário
seguramente não existe mais o gelo já
derreteu essas pessoas que estão ali
também existem mais porque o tempo
passou a minhas filhas que então tinham
cinco e sete anos hoje já estão com 20 e
o tempo passou pra mim também pra mim
também
então eu percebo que essa é uma uma
célula de um instante que já se foi
a fia é tão importante pra mim porque
nós nos transformamos ao longo do tempo
a outra fotografia que era muito
importante para mim era depois de um mês
no barco vem na antártica do nível do
mar
eu pedi pra subir no topo do mastro o
topo do mastro do do nosso bairro tem 33
metros de altura
mas é possível subir é só a gente
colocar uma cadeirinha vestir e 6 sábado
por uma corda até a ponta
a sensação de estar lá em cima é meio
que um pêndulo e conforme o vento bate o
só para e omar balança a gente sente
jogado de um lado para o outro
eu não vou negar que é divertido que eu
gostei mas é tem sempre um risco mas com
frio na barriga é mais legal e eu subi
com a câmera e sentir assim nós que
bacana poder olhar antártica daqui de
cima porque surge numa outra perspectiva
e e depois de um mês e olhando a
paisagem notadamente do nível do mar ou
no máximo em cima de uma montanha olhava
de cima tinha ganhado toda uma outra
importância pra mim e eu fotografando
tudo quase que como uma metralhadora na
mão fotografando sem parar por um lado
pro outro naquela tentativa é de
preservar um momento de tentar congelar
aquele instante também e eu não me
lembro quanto tempo eu fiquei lá em cima
mas eu me lembro do frio que eu sentir
sentir também o tempo passar porque
alguns barcos foram se aproximando do
nosso e atracaram junto a nós
não sei quanto tempo passou mas eu senti
meus dedos congelando mas era tão
importante pra mim tá em cima realizando
um sonho eu estava concluindo um projeto
que eu tinha me dedicado muito para ele
acontecer e passando o tempo começou a
nevar eo absorta bem distante
pensando quanto foi significativo aquele
momento
então eu ouvi um som que no começo não
entendi o que era
pois houve de novo eu tinha preparado de
fotografar porque tem momentos que a
gente tem que saber a hora de abaixar a
câmera e de viver muita gente fotografa
compulsivamente esquece de ver
fotografias essas que vão ficar dentro
de um celular ou um hd e nunca mais vão
ser vistas
então eu parei de fotografar
simplesmente para viver e aquele som
novamente que eu não sabia o que era
olhei para baixo e pude ver era o meu
próprio marido gritando marina desce daí
de cima
as fotografias que você faz não servem
pra nada
agora a gente ri lá na hora no renan
na hora foi bem difícil
a primeira sensação foi um susto aqui
vem em seguida foi aquela de engoli seco
depois disso eu respirei fundo e só
então eu comecei a chorar chorei chorei
chorei mais um pouco
eu tinha várias opções depois de ouvir
aquilo eu poderia por exemplo ter
largado a câmera tinha do mar poderia
também ter tirado a câmera nele na
cabeça
poderia também ter descido obediente
entrado no barco guardado a câmera na
cabine e nunca mais ter falado sobre
isso
foi um episódio muito marcante mas
enquanto estava em cima
misturando lágrima com neve eu comecei a
lembrar da minha vida e como um filme
passando pela minha cabeça eu comecei a
pensar o que tinha levado até ali
aí me lembrei que eu ficava meses na
praia em paraty na bahia zinha do
jurumirim vendas crianças crescerem
olhando o horizonte e pensando onde será
a câmera está
quando será que ele vai voltar será que
ele está bem e as meninas sentindo muita
saudade do pai durante muito tempo na
nossa vida eu fui pai e mãe é difícil
a gente lidar com a saudade com a
ausência inclusive nas festinhas de
escola cobrir a falta do pai quando só
gente de mãe e os outros são pais mas a
gente vai aprendendo muita coisa
foi então que pensei tive uma grande
idéia
eu lembrei assim quer saber
na próxima vez que ele foi fantástica a
família dele vai também e então nós
fomos plantar fica pela primeira vez em
família
foi uma viagem transformadora para todos
nós e na volta essa volta foi mais longa
que ainda porque ainda tinha aquela
tristeza dentro de mim
chegando no brasil e voltei a realizar
minhas festas concluir os eventos que já
tinha contratado que já estava tudo
acertado que eu tinha é assumido a
responsabilidade de realizar
entreguei as festas mais incríveis os
sonhos mais alucinantes nos clientes que
cada vez exigem mais da gente e eu
percebi que da verdade estava sendo uma
fada madrinha da realização dos sonhos
dos outros
foi então que resolvi encerrar a minha
carreira de produção de eventos
fechei a minha empresa e abrir minhas
gavetas
organizei o conteúdo que já tinha
guardado e montanha na primeira
exposição de fotografias em seguida eu
tive convite para montar outra e outras
e outras vieram na seqüência
então eu passei a ver a vida com novos
horizontes
o mundo novo se abriu para mim foi então
que eu passei a ter outras experiências
além da antártica o ártico e porque não
a aurora boreal então organizei o
primeiro livro pra minha filha junto com
elas nós fizemos um livro chamado férias
na antártica onde as fotografias
passaram a servir para mais coisas ea
história começou a fazer mais sentido
pra mim tive coragem e tenho meu
primeiro livro com tática a última
fronteira esse livro rapidamente esgotou
então publiquei um segundo livro
antártica olhar nômade
que o fotógrafo de natureza ele tem um
olhar nômade ele tem que fazer parte e
se sentir parte daquele lugar 100 ea
pertencia a ele
e assim a gente vai circulando e
viajando e vivendo novas experiências
sugiro então os convites para falar em
público e eu pensei por que não
compartilhar essa coragem que um dia eu
tive de recomeçar porque não poder
compartilhar essa coragem de se
reinventar
muito embora a gente esteja no auge dos
50 anos
quando a gente acha que a gente tem que
se acomodar é hora da gente se levantar
e começar tudo de novo
então eu criei coragem e comecei a
compartilhar essas idéias que é possível
a gente sonhar e que nunca é tarde pra
gente começar e as fotografias que até
então não tinha servido para nada
começaram a servir pra muito mais coisas
do que eu podia imaginar
hoje olhando aquele dia do grito eu não
sinto mais dor a dor que eu senti
eu sinto a gratidão porque um dia o amir
teve a coragem de dizer pra mim que
aquelas fotografias não serviam pra nada
e não teriam servido mesmo se eu não
tivesse tomado uma decisão de de criar
um novo projeto e trabalhar com ela de
maneira diferente
hoje eu sou muito grata por essa
oportunidade que eu tive de recomeçar
esse novo horizonte que se abriu para
mim e eu acho que quanto ao trabalho
o futuro é bem imprevisível a gente
nunca sabe o que vai acontecer mas eu
acho que a experiência que a gente tem
na vida os recomeços que a gente tem da
vida que a gente constrói isso é o
suficiente pra gente ter coragem de
recomeçar a qualquer momento a gente
pode começar uma vida nova a qualquer
instante e não tem uma data certa pra
isso e nem tem uma idade certa pra isso
eu mergulhei fundo na minha ideia no meu
próprio interior naquilo que eu mais que
isso pra mim e foi mais alto do que eu
podia imaginar
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]